okay
um welcome to the slightly earlier
version of the revenue Workshop today
under long-term plan
um
so yeah not in the early time or one
o'clock
um apologies we have apologies from
councilor pottinger
councilor Bond and the mayor do we have
any other apologies from the forums
councilor Stuart sorry yes councilor
Stewart um it was called away as well
okay all right
okay so
um the purpose of the workshop really
and it's going to take us through this
so um purpose of this Workshop is really
to look at those sources of non-rates
revenue that council's got some
opportunity to consider
um making changes or adjustments to our
approach on
um so we've already been working on fees
and charges for the last few years
through the annual plan and we'll
continue to do that but Patricia's going
to draw attention to some areas of focus
there development contributions
um something for cuts or to consider and
then finally a conversation around what
other commercial and collaboration
Opportunities Council could consider and
getting some strategic direction from
you about where you would like to focus
so this Workshop will really input into
both the financial strategy and the
revenue and finance policy and you have
a copy of that policy on your desk as
well as into activity planning
okay so Patricia's going to take us
through
this thank you sorry
um I thought I'd just do a bit of a
breakdown of where our sources of
revenue are so
in the 2021-22 annual report is the
slightly smaller donut are the bigger
ones what's sitting currently in the
draft annual plan for 23 24th
traditionally invercargill's been around
that 50 50 rates 50 non-rates Revenue
what we've seen in the last since from
the last ltp right through that we're
getting closer
to being 60 40.
well we've got a legislative requirement
that we can't have more than 60 of our
Revenue being rates right
so we've got that but it's it's showing
the change
um
we're getting
grants and subsidies and grants revenue
is a moving face traditionally would
have been seen to be the wakakatahi
subsidy for roading but given the
capital investment that we're doing at
the moment that's where all uh the three
Waters additional funding's been coming
through shovel ready has been coming
through there
as will their third party funding for
so that will
um swing it but we need to be trying to
come up with a consistent
sources of revenue outside
of Rights
um
dividends
come in there we won't be seeing
cevention Revenue any further because uh
Inland Revenue has changed the tax
legislation as it applies to us and we
can no longer create tax losses for
which we're selling to the group
can I just ask them Patricia we were we
were receiving some vention payments
directly from eil does that include that
or do we look upon that as a dividend
bank it's this adventure uh no they were
buying our tax losses so that's why we
were receiving the revenue
so we had tax losses which we sold
so that's where it got through so really
we're trying to look at where
you know we either inclusive fees and
charges
it's whether rental properties come
through with their rents
fines is so small it's probably not even
worth including
and then you've got interest which we're
at the mercy of the markets on so those
are our main sources of revenue
currently
um there's nothing
um and that's where part of this is to
explore
how we might move that and there'll be
some further discussions later on when
Steve will um look at other potential
other options that we've got if you want
to move the slide
Rihanna the revenue and financing policy
is one of the policies which we'll have
to review as part of the long-term plan
preparation but this is the one that
sort of directs
and actually outlines in that policy for
each of our activities how they'll be
funded
and those councilors that have been
around the table before remember it's
often is it mud is it to be fully rates
funded is it to be
fully they use a pace or is it to be a
mixture of the two and this is where
that direction as we go through fees and
charges there's a couple of areas where
perhaps we may need to change that as we
go through the ltp process
to get that balance right
um
the policy also is it says that there
will seeks out all the sources of
revenue
as well as where we think
how we're Distributing the benefit from
our services or the benefit from
payments
we go to the next one again Ranna
so this is what we had for the last ltp
probably
not the easiest to read up there
but
it showed how we were funding our
different activities
so is within the policy which you've got
on the table in front of you if you want
to refer to it
probably actually easy to read in there
actually
there's no patch numbers
um
so something like
roading because it's on top of the last
there's very few user fees coming
through there which would be the parking
activity
um we get some subsidies from our petrol
tax but the majority that's funded
budgeting rights isn't to
who who
um
who best uses that
and then something like water supply
of saying the majority of it's funded by
a targeted rate because only those that
use that activity
the decisions been made that only those
that use that activity
should pay for that activity
though there is a recognition that
there's some user fees but also that
there may be some additional Revenue
sitting in there
so this is the discussion as we come
through in the staff of busy preparing
activity plans and asset management
plans
to go is there any change of funding and
where they will necessarily be looking
for direction for changes and that
and should we be putting a greater
Reliance on what should be user fees
user pays versus list to what would be
rates funded whether it be general or
targeted
so any questions about that
so what
the assumption is that we're
what what level of central government
funding comes through this
um so the subsidy column and petrol tax
is sort of your central government
funding so eroding at the same time is
we're doing a long-term plan we're also
in discussions with wakakatahi on the
level of funding that they may have yeah
and it will come together hopefully
towards the end at the same time yeah so
so then looking forward on the ltp if
you look at say housing
um
the sentiment seems to be there's more
appetite for central government to
become involved in partnership with
local government and even private sector
around
supplying that
so so how will this change
going you know through the ltp is what
I'm trying to sort of get a sense on not
perhaps an answer but I think it's
important for us to understand where
this could go to in terms of what could
move and change in this thing and and
within the saotic pay or the first three
years of this ltp we may have to do some
address some issues water would be a
classic yeah yeah that we're going to
have to address that one and housing May
well be depending on on where we sit for
the time we come to adopt an ltp that we
we set the policy will get adopted
um at the same time as we also before we
adopt the ltp isn't it Rihanna
yeah so we intend to have the policies
with you before Christmas to be
confirmed but there still may be some
changes ahead of being adopted for
consultation
late February
so I'm getting ahead of myself okay
thank you
housing is a good one about and that's
probably one that many people may not
realize is that for us a housing care
activity is fully
um do you suppose so there is no
take from the general rates
for that activity and can I just add
that we have consulted on that before
and that has been the indication from
the community that they're very happy
for Council to continue it
but
the percentage
was in favor of it not being a draw on
rates
but it but it's equally it's a growing
it's a there's a growing demand for it
isn't it yeah
yeah but let's work on our existing
stock that needs to be done yeah that's
right yeah and another consultation may
see a different result on the feeling of
the community about the possibility of
some race contribution yeah yeah and and
so is there a
you know how how well informed is their
Community to make that decision around
where that should be funded in terms of
understanding the need demand
in sort of you know the alternative if
we don't fund it until I think it's
probably an important piece of
information to get them before they make
a decision isn't it yeah that
consultation was done enough years ago
for it to be refused new information
that goes out yeah I think it could be
easily updated because the one thing we
never took into account was the need to
upgrade the facilities and and whilst we
were treating water
um with the the charges that are you
know subsidized market rate
um it didn't allow perhaps for some
general rates contribution to to gather
the interest and upgrading the stock
yeah yeah okay sorry about it
it was never an option
so probably the
the biggest one of the biggest areas
we've got to revenue is our fees and
charges
and the italics on the side of on the
right hand side as you look at it off
that straight from the revenue and
financing policy so
if I was to take it simply basically
fees and charges are basically saying
those that use the service pay for the
service and to cover those costs where
the more that people use it
the more it costs
so it's only fair that someone who's a
high user
pays for that service and typically
often used for services that may be
provided to those that don't pay rates
or don't live within the um
that live within the city yeah it's that
Regional Center
yeah even then there are some of those
things that we charge for now
that I think are overdue for review uh
liquor licensing charges for example I
haven't been reviewed since we peeled
them back after people were abhorred at
a 180 increase
um actually when you boiled it down to a
dollar value is not much
um but the the industry hadn't been
allowed to adjust for over 20 years
um development contributions was one of
those things that was up in one of the
earlier slides and it's been more than a
decade since we last canvassed people
um about that as as well and even Animal
Control charges at the moment there's I
think a slight contribution from the
general rate but it could be reviewed
because the rest of the funding goes on
dog owners which is unfair because not
all animal control activity relates to
dogs so those are things that are
probably due for review in the next yeah
realm and those are the sort of levers
that we've got so you've picked the
obvious ones there are I don't know
there are some that are set by
legislation
um and the one that comes to mind all
the time is the inspections of amusement
devices which is Ferris wheels and the
likes which
actually the statutory fee for that will
charge for that service
doesn't cover the after as call out fee
um but that's what the legislation says
we can charge so we have been vocal
about that in the past but there is
other areas where
um there is a potential for review
and more focus on full cost recovery if
that was desired
just a bit of a
well one don't want to sleep for it or
not but do we have a
policy statements lesson
Vision around
you know provisional service
so
you know how wide and far do we go
around the services we provide
obviously somewhere legislated to
provide but others
you know and be interesting to get
community feedback because often it
would be otherwise that the community
expects everything but doesn't want to
pay for anything it's the you know and
that's not being disrespectful Community
that's just a you know we all want more
for the list don't we do we have any
sort of so that will come through with
each of the activities
um plans for the ltp so this is what
they will deliver right um what they
could deliver in this community and put
into those part of the consultation as
well yeah so
um the workshops that will be held in
July
um you'll get information on all of the
activity planning and the asset planning
and the manageable will raise to you
issues that they believe whether we're
either an increase or decrease in the
level of services worth considering
um some of the earlier workshops we've
had in the process have been
highlighting issues and getting
direction from you counselors which has
informed and will informed those
workshops in July
so whether we consult on a particular
issue will be dependent on the scale of
it and whether it meets requirements to
consult on the significance and
engagement policy so some smaller
changes that would not be a great impact
on the level of service you wouldn't
consult and others we definitely would
and that's what we'll do next march okay
thanks
do you want to move it forward
facing charges is probably there's three
areas or two areas where I think
there is the biggest opportunity
for us to consider changes
um first is regulatory so Jonathan do
you want to
jump in here because this is
predominantly all yours where
currently we've probably got some
settings that need to be reviewed
right so three you chair
um yeah so uh looking at the regulatory
side of things uh we can see some scope
for some adjustment uh we believe that
the service we're providing now meets
the expectations of the community I
think it has to be acknowledged that
previously there were some areas where
perhaps that wasn't the case we're
satisfied it meets the needs of the
community
um but there are some questions around
do we have the ability to deliver it at
a lesser rate that will come through in
the activity management plans it's
arguable that some of the systems we use
um we could some we could be using a
Rolls-Royce system when a Mazda system
would work better for a simple analogy
some of the other areas we're looking at
um in general the concept would be that
the user does pay and that seems fair
and Equitable there are some areas where
the user may be paying
um they're using our service under
duress and most of those are in
compliance type activities
where where Duty bands follow-up
complaints and resolve them yes we do
have the ability to infringe and find
people but sometimes that leads to not
particularly positive outcomes
um a good example is probably one of the
more recent cases we've had in the
environment Corps where we've been
forced to prosecute a property owner for
hoarding a lot of stuff on their site
that wasn't in accordance with the
district plan
it was the right thing to do to
prosecute and enforce a district plan
however it was accepted by the judge
that the individual didn't have the
ability to pay any fines so it's gone to
community service that's the cost of
that action still has to be funded
through cancer
so these are some of the things that we
have to consider
um likewise with abandoned vehicles
um where we have an abandoned vehicle
that's been burned out the community
expectation is that that's removed as
quickly as possible and resolved
locating the owner of that vehicle is
going to be nigh on Impossible they take
steps to ensure we can't locate them all
the vehicle's being stolen however it's
still going to be funded so it
it's not I think with regulatory it's
not as simple as saying user pays
ideally user pays but there are some
areas that we just have to anticipate
that Community
um has to put in some have some skin in
the game as well
I think that probably covers it yeah
just want to reinforce
um the next year really will be for us
looking at ways that we can provide the
service at a lesser rate and that will
involve looking at some of our systems
so we're perfectly happy to have that
conversation and see what we can do to
improve outcomes
the other one we wanted to um raise here
was probably the fees and charges for
water
so
as counselors will recall at the moment
air fares and charges are out for
consultation for the annual plan
oh let's finish consultation they're
about to come back where we increase the
water
rights to reflect how much it was
costing to um
to deliver that service to deliver that
for
be you omitted water
but as we go into the ltp we need to be
mindful about the impact of affordable
the affordable water reforms
and what that could do
to what uh rate pairs will be paying for
that service going forward
so it's just a it's we've raised it's an
issue because I know initially
um staff had thought that the cost of
water from meters could be significantly
more
because we have highlighted that it
would be a greater cost
um under affordable water for
invercargill City
so when you talk affordable water
reforms that's through the three three
Waters using its new name
so
yeah
an increase on warm shadow
and it went through quarters
would wouldn't that actually allow a
stepping stone into to that other price
because it's like anything if you have
influence into something because it
doesn't seem so much
because your pet she had to accommodate
or manage the exercise but if you've
ever
a low to a high
it can be quite significant I'll just
saying that yeah and that was part of
some of the thoughts of making sure that
we are reflecting the cost of delivery
yeah yes when we did the consultation
that's coming yeah
when we did the proposed increase that's
just finished the consultation we didn't
choose the highest possible level by any
means we chose
a
a more reasonable increase than could
have been suggested consider considering
the details we had about the cost yeah
yeah
or maybe I think was between it was 17
190.
um I can't remember what we've got
we certainly didn't go for the horse no
we went we went for
the middle yeah it was about 130 yeah we
yeah yeah
we didn't go there
okay
Jonathan
three chairs so development
contributions
um there's two parts to this essentially
they need a lot of Prior planning and
preparation and they also need certainty
of where your growth areas are going to
be
um feedback from other councils that
have implemented development
contributions indicated that it has been
successful where they've been in the
planning stage up to two years before
the long-term plan side of things
um you can get a fair amount of pushback
from developers
um as as is to be expected but you you
need to have certainty that you're going
to have large growth in areas and know
that that's going to go through because
otherwise you can end up with
development contribution nurses in place
and then there's no growth there so they
largely become ineffective
um there's also the issue of central
government Direction in regard to um
trying to bring the urban centers in and
up as opposed to out and about uh with
Brownfield development councils have run
into issues where proposing to upgrade
systems to enable brain field
development
um provides a disproportionate amount of
betterment to properties that are
already already connected there but
aren't necessarily going to be paying an
additional charge whilst and properties
that develop connected to those Services
as well
so
um it's something that has to be thought
through carefully it has to be planned
and we would need to be really certain
where our growth areas were going to be
and that they were going to be high
enough growth to justify
um development contributions
foreign
so I think the other aspect of
development contributions because there
was very
firm pushback from developers who
claimed that you know two or three
thousand dollars of DC's was actually
going to tip there
um proposals over which was nonsense
um but they can also be used as a tool
to encourage development in specific
areas so for example if there are parts
of the city where infrastructure is
nearing capacity or is going to need to
be expanded
you could have a higher level of
development contribution but for
specific things because you need to let
people know what it is that they're
contributing towards but at the same
time if
for example you were wanting to
encourage more Brownfield development
without us having to extend the services
then there might be a lesser development
contribution but as Jonathan pointed out
there's still that whole if you're
increasing the number of titles on a
site there is actually increased
pressure on the the system through that
so I guess it's figuring away
of looking at staged development
contributions as to where you have them
but it's certainly it's been over a
decade it's worth absolutely worth us
going back out and raising this with the
community again
so so
if if we
introduce a development contributions
policy
it it would be on a cost recovery so
that
so that the any cost that the rate
payers had to be for that development
would be recovered through that
development I think we have to identify
where the development is going to create
so a development that
um requires for example putting in
stormwater and sewage is fine so they
have to put that infrastructure in but
then it's up to the city to maintain it
whereas
a portion of the DC could perhaps be
allocated towards the maintenance we
used to I think we looked at development
contributions going towards parks and
reserves well obviously if we're looking
at reducing the number of parks and
reserves that's not something uh
specific but it's figuring out what it
is that they can be
contributing towards that's that's going
to be the key
Lizzy were you thanks Mr chair I I just
remember when I first came on Council I
seem to remember there was a working
party looking at development
contributions at that time and the
conclusion was that the administrative
overheads made it at that stage
and unattractive
proposition and it may be time that we
address that but I think that's that
Edmund overheads issue is one that you
have to bear in mind that would be part
of a paper wouldn't it if it's if we're
going to do this what's that cost to
recover yeah I mean at the time when we
first consulted it it was
we didn't go with it because we wanted
to see something happening
and we saw developing contributions as
perhaps being a discouragement towards
them
but my Council supper is right there are
costs associated with it as well yeah
okay
so the
next one we wanted to discuss with you
was generating Revenue through community
services and I asked
um Steve to
three years cheer um
one of the things that the team are
working on continually is efficiency and
Effectiveness and the services we
deliver
um
but there are other ways in which we can
be more efficient especially with the
funding and
what I guess the revenue and financing
policy does not limit
our ability to do this but I think
previous discussions around the table
around previous initiatives around cafes
and around a little bit more commercial
activity in our space
has lent towards Council not wanting to
enter into competition with the
commercial sector with our business
sector
just wanting to put that out there as to
whether or not you actually want us to
bring Concepts forward
and you're probably three areas that we
can identify
and and it's not
unintentional that we've been reporting
Cafe performance at Splash Palace for
some time because
what it does show with a very clear
focus and a business strategy we can
actually turn essentially what was a
community service and good that lost us
money every year into a service that's
more valued by the community but also
generating
Revenue Surplus that goes back into the
pool's operations to help offset that
race rates take
uh that's taken a little bit of work but
it's been done all largely by in-house
staff with a with a clear focus and a
bit of a mandate
we could take that approach
similar eras such as the venues uh such
as the library
where we look to create that Community
hub
but not shy away from opportunities that
actually can generate
a commercial return whether that's
through lease space to a partner
business or whether or not that's
utilizing an existing infrastructure and
staff and expanding that scope of
service
so that's one option uh the second
option is around sponsorships and naming
rights
now
um
again probably more relevant in Splash
Palace but equally relevant to rugby
park if and when Council becomes an
owner of that asset
that the naming and sponsorship
opportunity is there and whether or not
we want to Target and actively go there
again not restricted from the revenue
and financing policy but
um a clearer direction would would be
quite beneficial
the final one is around product
development and promotion so that is
actually we become
we become a bit more active in that
commercial promotion and product
development place on that would be to a
degree in our venues at Civic Theater we
actually go and start bidding for events
and start developing events that have a
commercial return through the ticket
sales now that would take a lot longer
to do
but again another opportunity where
taking a taking a slightly different
approach to what a community service is
uh but not also shying away from the
opportunity to produce
uh an offset to a rates take or a user
fee
um
used to all three
so for the cafe and Retail Services
Retail Services I think are slightly
different in that if you've got a shop
associated with the venue of souvenirs
that's quite appropriate but there's
always been some pushback pushback about
us competing with the private sector
around cafes
it's worth remembering that it's not
untested territory because the cafe at
the Museum was previously leased out
and only stopped actually when the
existing leaseholder had over
capitalized
so we're lucky at the moment with Splash
Palace that we've got some staff who've
really managed to turn that around very
well
but that could just as easily tip off
and what's a constantly changing
fear so I'm more more in favor of us
leasing those spaces sponsorships and
naming rights you know it's a day after
one time it was called Erickson Stadium
but yesterday Mount smart was given to
go media rugby park was previously
Homestead
um which the ilt paid for and then they
gifted back the name of rugby park but
actually it's worth us and timely
examining that again because
um
we don't want to see it as just a rugby
venue there is a limit though I mean I
wouldn't go and sell off the Civic
Theater which I think with a cultural
thing as is potentially more
um fraught but at the Civic they have
recently moved into developing their own
products mostly for Activation of space
which is is really commendable it is
potentially fraught when you get into
speaking on events
um
particularly in this I want to say post
covered but it's not really in this in
the new now
um but it's it's worth a shot for the
for coming up with the right event to
activate a space like the Civic Theater
um all rugby pack that gets people into
into them that wouldn't normally be
there it might not necessarily be making
dollars for us but it is certainly
giving people a better sense of value
for money
um but all three of those suggestions I
think we should actively look at
welcome Ellen do you have any view on
that around no I'm you know I should
Gribble with Darren there I certainly
believe that um if you're going to have
cafes and Retail spaces the best option
is really to to list it out to private
Enterprise and just get the regular
lease money in rather than try and do
business yeah because business people
will always do business
better if it's their own business yeah
then somebody who actually um yeah has
an employee position to do yeah um
sponsorship and naming totally totally
agree I mean rugby park I mean at the
end of the day
um
which I should be renamed I mean you
might get a million dollars for it you
might get half a million dollars for it
and of course that goes a long way
towards uh the revampment of it doesn't
it
yeah product development and promotion
I'm not too sure what you can do with
that really to be clear
I don't want to buy a t-shirt with ICC
a Steve did you hit her well maybe you
do yeah yeah let's go let's let's go
invercargill
um
thank you look I and
just to put the other spin on it and
I've been involved in a number of
operations both here in Christchurch
where we've we've driven something
ourselves
um because the challenges
uh which is around that service element
is if if the council does it
uh We've basically got all the overheads
and everything contained and and we
should be operating on a mandate of when
the doors open the service starts
the difference between that approach
because that's the approach we've taken
at Splash Palace
we're starting to sell coffees at six
o'clock in the morning and we don't stop
selling food until about 8 30 9 o'clock
at night
we we can then extend the operating
hours and and provide that service now
the challenges when you provide that to
the commercial Market
they're overheads and their cost model
and their cost barriers determined
sometimes the opening hours of those
Services aren't always aligned to our
facilities and so that the flip side of
that is we get we get a steady source of
income which I completely agree with
Alan on that point
um but we don't maximize the income
because maximizing means you're selling
as soon as you've opened and you stop
selling is pretty much when you shop
that's the difference between us being
really focused on revenue and our
community services versus being more of
a passive land facility manager and the
difference in product development too is
at the moment we're doing product
development for Activation we're not
doing it for Revenue
um we talk about different risks and a
different skill set in that space so
that that's just to give you the context
and it's not to say if you go the
leasing space that's fine because it
actually is a little bit easier
um
but we also miss a little bit too
because we're making a lot more money
now at Splash Palace than we would do
through a commercial lease
and so that's the benefit of offsetting
rates that that you may trade off yeah
and I think another piece there I'll
come to you in a minute um you know
there's that complimentary service isn't
it that someone can go to the pool at
six o'clock and get a coffee which yeah
commercially probably but because you've
got those Services connected to another
service that the museum would be another
example the library probably could be
another example and it's just it's a bit
of a tweak and difference to us but
we've got to really understand the
benefit because there is a cost to serve
so yeah come on
say something similar actually I mean
you might find that you do sell the odd
coffee at six o'clock but if it's
commercially viable a commercial person
will be doing that anyway that's right
otherwise it's going to be costing you
money and actually costing you Revenue
okay because you might have somebody pay
on the ticket selling the tickets but
then you're still going to have somebody
to look after the coffee and if you're
doing three or four coffees in there
believe me you're not making any money
whatsoever is costing you money yeah
yeah so um
that's commercial reality yeah yeah
that's right yeah thanks chair I was
going to say if we were if we're
exploring that particular one any
further I'm just thinking
the example of a Queen's Park Cafe
operation
may be one that is worth
um
doing a little bit of a case study on
it's at least there's no could we least
said it is
probably that has been you know it's a
it's a it's running it's a long time yes
it is for a very long time
which is which would be an interesting
case study to look at along with a case
study of the splash Palace operation is
our own operation and just to that end
because that would be useful information
going forward with the museum wouldn't
to have sort of have a good
understanding around what our best
option is yes
yeah so one thing I forgot to mention
here was under sponsorships and naming
rights I think something we need to be
wary of is that what we're interested in
is cash
um because there are a lot of
sponsorship deals for events and venues
and I'm not using go media at um at the
the stadium in Auckland as an example
but you will get media organizations and
yes this comes from my jaundiced
experience of working within them who
offer reciprocal trade agreements
contract yeah and that's worth nothing
to us they'll tell us oh it's you know
it's fifty thousand dollars worth of
advertising which is rubbish because
that's at full rate which they never
charge but if the if a media
organization is coming forward with
money as a car dealer would be that's
that's fine yeah
the other
yeah it's all about the money show me
the money
um the other thing I think is you know
if you're gonna go down a growth
opportunity in a business or you know
even in this Council you always play to
your strengths so how well do we
understand their strengths and
you know I know for a fact that the
South and District Council get a Dunedin
company coming to mow their lawns
yeah we have a lawn mowing
you know a good ground keeping facility
can we leverage that up and do it across
a water Network as an example like is
that a strength of airs that we could
leverage or I'm only using the example
not saying we shouldn't explore that
right but you know coming back to the
principle if you always play to your
strengths what are your core strengths
and that's the areas if we find any we
should try to grow
um and then I think the other piece is
just around the you know if there's a
complimentary service that we can offer
we've probably got to do that might not
be as commercially viable as the normal
commercial operation would see it but it
it works for us in other ways I think
that also works within and I won't use
lawn mine because I know we're short
staffed there but
um and other services that Council
provides in our regulatory arm we
provide support to other councils yeah
um
are we charging enough for it because if
we're just covering our costs it's worth
it we're just loading up more work on
our staff if if we're making good money
out of it and saving somebody else the
problem of of having those overheads
yeah that's worth it to them
um and I think if if it's keeping a full
workload on our staff
and they know that it comes with a real
value to council as well that is another
way of of managing what we have and on
selling yeah and the other thing if you
talk if you look at the park service for
example you know there could be
opportunity that comes out of us growing
the air through you know we get to grow
our own more because we've got more
opportunities to grow apprentices and
through that thing so we just by being
bigger you get more advantages in this
example absolutely
uh just a sort of add a wheat head to
the product development type stuff and
you know and the given that we've got
sales at Specialists and at Queen's Park
and things like that I mean with this
new vibe
CBD here you know product development is
a promotion type materials I mean
would sell quite well through some of
those premises because everyone wants to
have something from the cargo of the
visiting so if you're talking like for
tomorrow
or
or those sort of type things
and other people wanting to jump on that
bandwagon you know I mean we could
probably charge them in some way or form
yeah
just a thought yeah all right if you
develop the right product exactly yeah
and you know we sort of started down
that path with that invercargill
CBD uh branding that we came up with
with the big eye which everybody caught
on to yeah which is cool it's
interesting that the South and rugby
Jersey
is one of the most common rugby jerseys
that you can see in a crowd at
International games yeah it's one of the
more yeah it's one of the biggest
sellers in NPC rugby behind the All
Blacks yeah that's right so if you come
up with the right product
we've talked about
um we've talked about what we could do
in a CBD and you know some of those apps
that you can get um that could tell the
story of how it's developed the way that
morning that we had yes you know that
would be a product we could sell into
the hotels or have available even to
hire yeah I don't I mean it have to be
costing so that it was yeah advertising
on it yeah yeah that's a good example
that would be fantastic that your
wheelhouse Steve
it
yes sorry about that
um
but it's part of the products we're
talking about products we're talking
very widely this year about the form of
those products we're not just talking
about a t-shirt or a mug or whatever
we're talking about potential for use of
intellectual property and I.T and yeah
so yeah it probably is Steve uh yes
um the reason why it's a strained yes is
what we'd actually need the policy to
say and have that commitment around this
table is that actually is something you
want us to go and start investigating
because if we if we do all the work yeah
and we bring it back and then you go
don't compete with local business
because local business could do it
better then I think we should that's
probably the benefit of having the
conversation now
to get that Clarity to go do you want us
to because if we do we will
but then don't be surprised when we
bring back the answer this is we can do
it better yeah or we can't
um and so that's probably where the
policy needs to be helpful for us to say
we want to go into this direction and we
recognize we are going to enter into a
space we haven't been in actively before
but
we're prepared to for these reasons or
work and partnership with others to
develop these things because they are
two different approaches we can do both
what we need is the policy to direct us
as to which one you would like us to
achieve or how you would like us to
achieve it yeah and just Alex has just
made a comment on
um
the chat re you know to that example
partnering with local businesses like
digital stock to be able to bring
something to the market so youth
yeah can I can I just make the point
Steve it's not that we haven't been in
it before I'm just thinking about the
former Museum shop
where we were selling
some obviously branded invercargill
products that were made in some cases by
other invercargill firms and so forth
so I'm just thinking to some extent we
have been in before yeah and it may be a
very good further exploration
considering that 1225 is
not that far away and we yeah want to
think about
the cafe and Retail aspect of
what is in our new Museum
and that would also sorry through you
yeah they would also counter um what you
were saying about competing with other
businesses like we got businesses to
develop it and then sold it in in the
museum or somewhere it gives other
people an opportunity for him yeah I
just wanted to share because the toner
move it was being sold out of the museum
was locally carved that's right yeah and
I see everyone there if they wanted a
real piece of genome
I would send them to the museum yes and
there were locally local blown glass
works and yeah and is it also something
we could chuck too you know the young
entrepreneurs thing that the schools run
and and Link them in to say come up with
some ideas and maybe Chuck out some
some thoughts like a you know digital
app or the museum you know what what
ideas are there young people in the city
got about how we could make more money
out of the museum you know it could be
something to throw at them and put it
through that young entrepreneurs thing
and see what they come back with
um through each year um look I think
that's The Balancing Act of what's
directly driven and taken on by Council
versus watts or do we just act as a
passive landowner and seek Partners to
come and do that job and in a way they
both deliver
listen a revenue in an income stream
but
one is a lot more close to our operation
the other is a lot closer to the
commercial and the business sectors
operation and way of doing things and
there might be mixes yeah but it's to
what degree do you want Council and
staff in particular to really
investigate a delivery option there
versus a partnership option so it's
actually we'll always partner with local
business when it makes sense to
um
but it's whether or not we're driving
that or whether or not and we lease that
out and just hope someone else does that
yeah that's probably the kind of the
keynote yeah not of that problem and so
that's why if I step back I think rather
than policy would come up with guarding
statements like you know Growers drinks
because that's directional what you'll
find
what what we'll find probably is that
for some you know some opportunities
it'll be a direct link and others will
partner and you know whereas we get too
specific and say well it's only going to
look like this
you know we we probably could miss
opportunities but equally chase down
some dreams that we're just going to
drop you know we're going to be for it
so it's more what are the guiding
principles around where we look to grow
revenue and invest and if we have those
guiding principles they give us that
sense check to say yep it meets those
principles let's go and get started to
investigate it further and bring back
the information as opposed to us have a
policy and staff run around trying to
get stuff to meet the policy or find
stuff that does method
value in the audio type storytelling
stuff because that's what we've been
trying to do yeah with the new
development here instead Street all of
that
you know there's an opportunity for you
know to invest in something like this
and
and leave that type of stuff but like
the other stuff I think you know music
partnership yeah and equally with it
there's a great partnership there
between look at that storytelling around
the CBD with
you could actually do that in a
partnership yeah
all right good discussion thank you all
right next
I was sort of got well
the next steps for um stuff we're going
to take that the guidance and the five
things for the nights that I've been
taking down and what we've been hearing
is that
they're open
to us looking for other ways of
generating Revenue
but we need to be very mindful of
partnership
of what our strengths
and
what probably was probably less clear as
whether
we can or cannot compete against
local but I think it was work with
was what I was hearing it was it was
there was no clear in it either way
um yeah I think the key through each
year is that we want to generate Revenue
it's not we want to develop products so
much is we want to develop pro products
with a view to
generating more Revenue yeah
combination yeah but you know for this
point the focus is that yeah so like I
think I'd be good to bring back you know
some of those principles around you know
grow airstrings partnering with
community
you know so leverage the community
strengths you know look for
opportunities to partner with other key
stakeholders that be it
um youth
um you know self alive you know some of
these
stakeholders that are you know
got some good capability if you like and
that's probably another principle was
you know make sure
capabilities understood
so so is it stands so I think we're
bringing asset and activity plans back
in front of you in July and August when
yep so the next Workshop after this one
um will be on the financial strategy and
the infrastructure strategy so we'll
start by bringing to all of these
conversations together and then you'll
get the detailed overview of each
activity in July
activity
staff will have gone through and
considered where they think that funding
source for their intimidation set and be
seeking feedback
for you on that from you on that
cool
yeah that's us but I think you to those
on live stream and thanks Alex for
joining us on live stream and thank you
for the counselors coming on
thank you timing Tom
pardon good timing yeah yeah did I miss
anything
it was so many big decisions
no David